>> Laura: THE STORIES BEHIND
THE HEADLINES WE TURN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR OF THE
FORTHCOMING WISEMAN WHO FOUND
CHRISTMAS RAYMOND ARROYO.
ALL RIGHT THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO
BE APPEARING A LOT OF CONCERTS
AT ODD MOMENTS OF LATE.
>> LOOK THIS IS ALL HUGE
DISTRACTION LAURA FOR WHAT'S
REALLY HAPPENING FOR PEOPLE WITH
NO DISCERNIBLE SINGING TALENT
THESE POLITICIANS HAVE DONE MORE
VENUES THAN LIVE NATION.
HE HELD THE BIG ELTON JOHN
CONCERT AT THE WHITE HOUSE EVEN
GAVE THE OTHER ROCKET MAN A
MEDAL.
IT WAS THIS BIZARRE MOMENT THAT
I THINK THAT EVEN TOOK
ELTON JOHN BY SURPRISE.
LIKE THE SINGER'S PLACE.
>> President Biden: BY THE WAY
IT'S ALL HIS FAULT THAT WERE
SUSPENDING $6 BILLION IN
TAXPAYERS MONEY THIS MONTH TO
HELP HELP FIGHT HIV/AIDS.
[LAUGHS]
>> IT WAS ALL HIS FAULT?
WHAT IS HE SAYING?
THE MAN IS TOTALLY OUT OF
CONTROL LITERALLY HAS LOST IN
THE FRAY.
>> Laura: THERE'S SO MANY
ELTON JOHN SONGS JOKES THAT
THERE'S SO OBVIOUS I'M NOT GONNA
SAY THEM, SUFFICES TO SAY THAT
ELTON JOHN AT THAT MOMENT LOOKED
LIKE HE WOULD RATHER BE
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
>> THE BLUNDERS ARE TO BACK.
ON A BILL THAT INCLUDED
MARIAH CAREY THAT CHART TOPPING
ARTISTS NANCY PELOSI TOOK THE
STAGE LAURA THE RECEPTION WAS
LITTLE CHILLY.
♪ ♪
>> I'M HERE TO THANK YOU.
[BOOS]
'S BECAUSE THEY ARE BLOWING HER
NOW THAT IS NEW YORK CITY IF
THAT IS ANY INDICATION OF THE
PUBLIC MOOD, NANCY PELOSI SHOULD
CONSIDER BEING A ROADIE FOR
ELTON JOHN.
THAT MIGHT BE A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE.
>> Laura: SHE MIGHT BE LOOKING
PRETTY GOOD THERE NEW YORK.
THE PRESIDENT AND JOE BIDEN ALSO
APPEARED AS A GLOBAL CITIZEN
EVENT AND FOR CROWD LOVE THEM.
>> A SPECIAL MESSAGE FROM
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
>> President Biden: IT'S GOOD
TO BE JOINING THING FOR HELP IN
THIS MOVEMENT MAKING BIG THINGS
HAPPEN.
[LAUGHS]
>> DO YOU HEAR THE BOOZE?
NOBODY IS BUYING THIS, THE BIG
THINGS HAPPENING IS MOSTLY
TROUBLING AND WHAT WE SEE IS THE
RAZZLE-DAZZLE.
YOU MENTION THE INFLATION WOES
AND CRIME SPIKING EVERYWHERE IN
MY HOMETOWN OF NEW ORLEANS NOW
THE MORTAL CAPITAL OF THE
COUNTRY, THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
IS DOWN 900 COPS.
THEY ARE TURNING TO CIVILIANS
FOR DETECTIVE WORK.
>> WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY
AS MANY AS 50 NEW CIVILIAN
POSITIONS.
WE WANT TO HAVE INVESTIGATORS,
CIVILIAN INVESTIGATOR TO GO OUT
ELSE I'M GO OUT THERE AND
COLLECT THAT EVIDENCE.
>> Laura: WHAT?
>> THAT IS THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
POLICE HE'S INVITING PEOPLE WHO
FAILED TO GET INTO THE POLICE
FORCE TO JUST COME ON IN THEY
WILL TRAIN THEM.
THIS IS BECAUSE THAT CONSENT
AGREE THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION IMPOSED ON THE
CITY.
THERE MORE COPS FILLING OUT
PAPER THAN ON THE B TONIGHT
BECAUSE OF THAT IT'S OUTRAGE.
>> Laura: WANT TO HAVE TO GET
RID I CONSENT.
IT'S OUTRAGE THEY HAVE TO GET
PEOPLE WHEN NECESSARY DO THE
RIGHT THING I'M NOT SAYING NOT
KIDS, BUT HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE NEW COMMIT
CRIMES AND ROWAN WAS FANTASTIC
AWESOME CITY.
ALL RIGHT AT THE SAME TIME YOU
KNOW WE SEE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TARGETING A PRO-LIFE
ACTIVIST AND PENNSYLVANIA?
THIS IS UNREAL TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> HE HAS A FATHER OF SEVEN AND
UP CATHOLIC WHO PRAISE OUTSIDE
OF A CATHOLIC TO ABORTION
CLINIC.
HE WAS ATTACKED BY A SQUAD OF
FBI ATTIC THAT AGENTS.
WERE AN IMPORTANT SUPPORTER OR
BULLY ATTACKED HIM AND HIS SON
SAID HORRIBLE THINGS TO THEM
INTERVENE ALLEGEDLY SHOVE THE
MAN.
HE LATER TRIED TO SUE HIM THE
CASE WAS THROWN OUT OF COURT,
WILL NOW THE JOE BIDEN JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SAID THAT HE HAS
VIOLATED THE FREEDOM OF ACCESS
TO CLINIC ENTRANCES ACT.
A FEDERAL OFFENSE WITH AN 11
YEAR PRISON TERM.
HIS TERRORIZING, PEOPLE WHO ARE
FAR FROM VIOLENT CRIMINALS AND
VIOLENT CRIMINALS WHO BEEN
THROWING COCKTAILS IN A PRO-LIFE
CENTERS LONG INVESTIGATION AT
ALL.
NONE.
THIS IS REALLY --
>> Laura: WHAT ARE THESE
TACTICS?
THIS WOULD ALL DICTATORS DO WITH
HER POLITICAL OPPOSITION.
TERRIFIES THEM AN ATTEMPT TO